The Context Management Specification, CMS, began at Duke University
as the Clinical Context Object Workshop or CCOW. It seeks to facilitate
the integration of diverse applications at the point of use. It does this by
managing issues such as, the identity of a patient. The user wants to view or
update, via these applications. The identity of the user who wants
to access the applications. A moment in time around which temporal data displays
should be centered by the applications. And a particular patient encounter,
that the user wants to review. The details are highly technical, but you can
get the general idea from this illustration, where several different ideas from
different vendors are all centered around the same patient at the same time for
the same clinician. This is and ambitious but potentially very important effort.
Since clinicians commonly complain about the time and effort involved to use
many different systems, that work in different ways to manage their patients.